when people talking about the greatest  ever I want to be in that conversation  I'm nowhere close to it but it's where I  want to go this is a story about the  rise because the more you rise from  struggle the more you appreciate where  you end up  we elementary school has no gym  practicing at a church helps to rise  when your high school doesn't have a big  name you rise to the occasion when  instead you're too small your body rises  eight inches you'd be no one get drafted  number one  you go up inside at home to making a  cloud rise and a home game  this about going for playing like your  idols to plant against them then playing  with them to rise together  so  what will your story be  NBA 2k16 star is quite weak joint